I can show you the ghouls goosy goosy
the goosey goose ingu singing goosing on
a magical ride goose goose eat the goose
time to fly with the goose goose goose
and the goosey goosey goosey ride
oh ho new goose a new Fantastic point of
goose non to tellus coos ho and a goose
a goosey goosey goosey goose with you hi
welcome it is time for the untitled
goose game I'm playing this in honor of
Ethan from crankin place I miss you I
miss you big goose he's not dead but his
channel is so rest in peace big guy big
goose I'll miss you up there
so I haven't been able to play this
because number one I've been in Korea
and number two I just got back from
Korea and so I haven't had much time so
I'm gonna play it right now so that we
can get our goose on because it's time
to goose and literally this is the only
thing that I've wanted to play my
controller oh there we go okay we're
good
so let's get the goose going I've never
played it I haven't seen any of it
but I know that it's going to goose real
good if we're gonna give him the goose
you got to blame it on the goose that's
my favorite thing Amy showed me the
remix of Liz O's gotta blame it on the
goose anyway
press X to honk goose I love it already
hi Hayden whole day to run oh yeah Oh
hello yes I mean you know it's funny
because I heard that the developer was
like why is this game so popular and
it's like can you imagine why this game
wouldn't be popular who wouldn't want to
play as goose
everybody wants a goose hello
LT to bend forward oh the perfect goose
control be to use your beak oh oh yeah
oh yeah now that's what I'm talking
about okay so if I find six more boots I
can get the goose mobile back up and
running I put this down here can I get
that wheel out of the the brush there
okay no apparently not mm-hmm okay
Bess been down to pick things up off the
ground
all right it's pretty good I'm sorry
I've just a little giggly goose today I
I just like this camera there's a real
nice game this is a real good game
that's a good game as a real good gamer
this is one of those good games it's
what you call a good game there we go
all right I got a master the abilities
of goostin
I'm not entirely familiar with the
process of being a goose so give me a
few minutes to adjust it and then I'll
be juicing my way to victory in short
goose order oh oh I'm a smart goose I'm
a real smart goose I'm the best goose
that ever was
come here you wait oh I'm a lot stronger
than I thought I was I am a mighty goose
just look at my caboose I'm a goose on
the loser everybody better watch it here
comes good hold the right trigger to
spread your wings was this just make me
more intimidating man sure I'm a girthy
goose excuse me as I well my my girth
the caboose
does that do anything I don't think it
does anything I'm a goose I'm sorry I'm
tickled to death by they said I don't
know why if if the developer can't
understand the pure joy of just playing
as a goose and being authentic to goose
eNOS I think they're just being a little
bit silly should I put this back in the
the pic-a-nic basket I got some goose
business over in the goose bushes I got
gotta go across the goose bridge here
excuse me just got it I don't know why
I'm taking this with me but I feel like
this is what I should do I don't know my
goose instincts are very strong I also
don't know what the main objective of
this game is other than being just a
regular old goose
hey that's locked all right whatever
fine then just be on my own goosey
business over here it's just gonna goose
my way this way yeah yeah the goose is
strong in me thank you I've always
suspected this to be true I'm glad that
it was confirmed in front of a panel of
my own peers so I appreciate the goosey
judgment what is this excuse me can I
attract a goose girlfriend or a mile 80
goose I'm a guessing I'm a big thick man
I got a lot of goose juice inside of me
if you know what I mean can I mother lon
is this the thing that I can do I really
hope it's the thing that they can do
games games on literally unplayable
I can't mow the lawn this is a garbage
game all right never mind
hey see your to-do list get in - I have
a to-do list get into the garden get the
groundskeeper wet
I got a lot of goose juice so I think I
know exactly what to do steal the
groundskeepers keys make the
groundskeeper wear his Sun Hat rake in
the lake have a picnic bringing to the
picnic blanket sandwich apple pumpkin
carrot Jam thermos huh oh okay oh okay
all right well I'll just be on my goosey
way excuse me I think the gardener might
need that but I need this for the picnic
no no no no no goose you let that go
Noah cous RL pullets over here you goose
all right come on goose there we go
[Music]
see I want out please
Oh oh my god hello Oh God excuse me Hey
what hey hey hey wait think it does yeah
gooshie in the next century dude look at
your a look at your caboose and then
compare it with my goose caboose you
can't even you can't even compare you
can't even compare sir excuse me I'm
just gonna yeah got it
ha ha ha oh god he's so fast he's so
fast well you don't like music what are
you a weirdo can I have the keys oh god
oh god I'm not exactly a stealthiest of
goose oh sorry you be stealth goose
incoming okay I want those keys aren't
those keys damn it this goose wants
those keys you better back off the goose
is on the loose oh come on both the
goose you good come on you oh yeah yeah
you think you think you think you don't
think you think you think you think ah
god I'm so bad I'm not the stealthy
goose I thought I was oh god I'm so
close come on please I just want I just
want this sweet delectable keys please
Eureka's I got him
Oh God okay okay yeah you can't beat the
Maggie goose why it was that an
objective oh I'm gonna get the
groundskeeper wet next oh let me put
this over maybe maybe if I take this
over to my my secret stash if I drop
this over here I'll have those keys
forever then I think that's how this
game works and if it's not how this game
works literally unplayable I can't even
believe it and I have no idea what to do
Oh
wait a minute I have free reign into his
garden because I got the keys this goose
is so smart and buy this goose I mean me
cuz I am the goose okay come here you
good goose no wait wait no no no no no
God do sit give me a goddamn good view I
hate you I hate you I hate you I hate
you I don't that's right you didn't even
think about it I got freaking Oh fine
fine fine fine fine
I don't know why I need those keys yet
so I'm just gonna let you be but I'm
coming for you when I do some goose
push-ups you you my friend
oh who you wanted this oh you stupid you
wanted this okay alright hang on wait
wait wait wait wait I got it I'm on my
way pardon me no he's so fast I'm gonna
be faster than a goose I thought a goose
was the fastest creature in existence
most powerful most drunk apparently this
is not the case
hey sup cabbage lettuce pumpkin are you
doing Oh kind of punk I'm gonna bumpkin
hey I can't I have some fun here you
suck Oh what what oh no come on you suck
so much
I'd want literally everything you ever
owned
yeah what do you think of that loser
okay alright anyway so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna explore a little more can I
open this is it too tall do I need to
stand on like a pumpkin do I need to use
the rake freakin the lake rake in the
lake was a thing flap perfect got it
raking the lake I know this I don't know
why rake in the lake bar rake is going
in the lake
why is rate going in the lake I don't
know why rink in the lake is a thing my
goose goose brains tell me only so many
things that I need to goose come here
you goose bastard get around the goose
corner there we go that's good stuff I
[Laughter]
did it guys I did it
gooses geese I did it my fellow geese
we're all my real geese at huh where's
where's goose gang huh where's my real
gooses I'm gonna go this way
I don't know why I needed a rake in the
lake but I feel really really
accomplished for this it more than any
other like objective-based game I've
ever played I feel like I've really done
it this time I feel like I've really
nailed this looks like I'm an elephant
now a goose ephant a long-nosed gusoff
er can I go in here oh no I cannot I
love I love that you can play a game and
just be like oh no I'm doing but I'm
having a good oh yeah hey go up here
wait wait for it wait okay
all right the rake is in the lake has
already been done so I guess I'm okay
not doing it further let's go leave this
right here that's good why is there a
baby pacifier here ten at ten can geese
out of ten this is the best goose I've
ever seen where the goose did this job
nurse yes hey drop that first thing can
I open this no it's one-way only okay I
see I see okay
all right well be put that down what
about the pacifier baby I don't know if
that's a good thing there's too many
weird connotations to this goose okay
I'm gonna take the bottle though games
news news news
[Laughter]
can I go in here no I can't why wouldn't
there be something in there all right I
would take this back I'm yours
we go over here wait what's over here
hello oh no okay hello hello what's with
all these one-way crap what is this try
and exclude me from the game all right
let me drop this for a second ah oh I
see oh I see
excuse me it wasn't me you you silly
silly man okay look I I need to get him
wet
oh yeah you're gonna get soaked oh you
go yeah what do you think of that
oh you're soaked oh you're stupid you're
so wet now you're just Birds nurse hey
Yahoo you goose hole what have you done
there what did I ever goofs to you you
can have a goddamn goose bottle don't
blame me for my goose behavior goose
what was that what's not a goose that
couldn't possibly have been a goose all
right so where's his picnic there was
another picnic also there was there's
some kind of a picnic I just got to go
find the picnic well just goose over
this way a little bit
oh I forgot this is the opposite of the
goose way that I need to goose
all right fine then I'll go over here
silly silly man
excuse me excuse me silly silly goose
more I like it do you not know the
difference putting a man and a goose or
something back here I bet there's a
secret something yeah no there's not
okay
gotta get my goose bottle goes alright
so what was the objective about getting
him wet other than just messin ruining
its entire day oh hi
pot you need pot you gonna smoke a joint
you're gonna smoke a fat goobie
you gonna slam down a big old goob
excuse me
Hey well I did nothing to you you're a
goose specious they're just species
against goose come here come at me you
bastard come at me you piece of crap I'm
gonna [ __ ] all over your dreams yeah I'm
gonna juice all over your nightmares oh
you're gonna see look at this waddle of
all you're gonna see is goose in the end
and you know oh he'll be goose I'm gonna
stick my goosey beak right up your
goosey caboose and you're gonna see the
what was that spooky goose I know I know
alright ok let me look at my to-do list
have a picnic bring to the picnic
blanket sandwich apple pumpkin carrot
Jam thermos radio basket ok where is the
picnic basket goose oh no way excuse me
pardon me and I know I need I know where
to get a pumpkin from the pumpkin yard
is this the picnic blanket I'll bring it
here first I guess I don't know where
else to get it so I'm gonna go get a
pumpkin and also the jam hey you mind if
I have one of these yeah you don't mind
it all I'll get the big one
oh the big one yeah all right scares me
I need this for stuff and things it's a
very important goose business you just
don't don't bother looking into anything
that I'm doing you you're stupid non-gay
sorry it's goose only don't like goose
okay there we go and Oh question mark is
this right feel like this is right yeah
this is this correct this correct okay
that is the picnic blanket I'm willing
to bet I will I'd be willing to bet my
entire existence
do they need a carrot I don't even
remember I'm gonna get one anyway
Italy dink okay that's good all right
just need I think you can turn quickly
if you let go of eight don't tell me how
to goose game
what no carrot what are you talking
about there was nothing no don't take my
carrot away from me I need it I need it
so badly okay excuse me pardon me why
you're so fast God why are you so fast
okay I'll get the radio then what are
you thinking about nothing stupid yeah
what are you gonna do good good what'd
you do god you're so you're so stupid I
hate you so much I hate you you gardener
you're so dumb don't flap your hands
like you're some kind of a goose I'll
get this did I need this I don't need
the cooler right now I don't need the
cooler okay let's get the real okay
going for it
goose on the loose excuse me that's not
the blanket hey yep it looks like a
blanket guys goose it looks like a butt
wait oh oh wait oh this is because the
bottle is there all right where is this
blanket then huh hey no you suck so hard
I hate you I hate you okay so what I
gotta do is I gotta find a way to get I
gotta find a way to get up here so I'm
gonna try to stack he's using my big
goose bread it's big goose time it's
it's beefy gusta I'm gonna use my big
goose brain to get up here what Oh
hello there you go sweet you get for
being you what hey wait what what I'm
having into you get a jerk hole do you
think you are ruining my goose fun I got
a lock him out a goose if I can just
lock him out okay what I gotta do oh
that's how okay
oh I'm locked in god I all right okay
all right never mind I got this I know
how to be stealthy goose I know 100% how
to stealth it where'd he go
I'm sorry oh there is hey listen don't
mind me just a goose just oh okay I know
how to do this
uh you'll never get me you'll never take
me alive no you'll never take me alive
you're not got your back brother yep
well I don't understand I understand
what you want from me I'm a little
confused
I'm not confused goose I'm goose
confused listen bud
where am I
[Music]
I'm a goose genius
guys I'm goose in it and I queue of 200
goose I've got the biggest goose that
ever did goose okay so now that I've got
this one all right so I kind of like
okay I cut out I got a sneak around
maybe there yeah there's actually
stealth mechanics here okay so all right
okay now that I know this now that I
know this now that I know I can't get
[Laughter]
[Music]
the entire goose can I climb over a wall
I need to flap can i flap I can't flap
[Laughter]
what oh yeah that's right that's right
hey hey hey hey I don't have them I
don't have a Meester Easter they're gone
Easter Easter Easter I'm sorry your your
possessions are all gone you're trapped
in here just like I am there it is got
it
ha ha okay I need to get out here
I need to get out of goosey danger
help stop fine fine
you suck Oh Oh
I'm free I'm free I'm free I'm free as a
goose I'm free as a glorious goose I'm
so goosey free this means okay with I
this watch biggest brain ever in the
history of forever forever okay biggest
brain ever boink he is stuck for all
eternity and if I can just smuggle
things out through the goose hole and
that's what this is this is most
indubitably the goose hole and that's
what we're all gonna refer to it as and
nothing else other than that how can I
pick I don't want that
alright fine I'll take the thermos all
right
just gotta make my way through the goose
hole ha ha I'm just I'm gonna I'm gonna
figure this out I'm gonna get it guys
just you gotta let my goose brain
develop goose naturally I don't want to
take goose roids oh yeah where's your
thermos that's weird that's odd hey I'm
gonna do it God you suck you suck so
much I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna do it goose her yet yeah but no no
no no not this time not this time I'm
wise I'm wise goodbye goodbye Oh God
the scariest thing I've ever experienced
in my entire I played Slenderman I've
played many many I'm five guys all right
by God all right here we go
I just need the radio hi where's your
jam hey listen don't shove me in my
goose hole excuse you goose goose that's
right that's right yeah you can't
you can't stop me you stay away from my
goose hole better show you what for
do I need the Apple to Apple yeah I need
the Apple all right goose it up soon
there's a horrible that gardener is
scarier than any other creature in any
other or game ever in existence I swear
okay I'm going into the goose bushes you
can't be me my goose boobs okay that's
right where do you think I am nowhere
stealthy like a bird it still feels like
a goose all right goose coming through
excuse me pardon me goose me goose okay
here we go got it okay so I just need
the radio I just need the radio Radio hi
goose excuse me okay I just need that
radio I just got to get that radio
that's it man you think this guy will
just take an ax to this goose I'm
waiting for the I'm waiting for the
spooky October shift in the tone of this
game okay I need aa piece what are you
gonna do we're gonna do but I'm goosing
up the neighborhood you're never gonna
get me you're never gonna get me for
that okay good
goose goose good good goose I did it
it's like a sim when you remove the
ladder from the pool I guess I'll die I
guess I'll just die what what
I'm frickin sorry did it just go through
that
what how did he do that how how did it
he's more powerful than vandals he's
unbeatable
you have no idea you have no idea Oh
what oh oh yeah that's right he can hear
it
excuse me sir goose goose in through all
right that's right yeah that's right you
have no chance fun to give up use more
exercise you've ever gotten in your
entire life okay no more ghosts
no more goostin through things my good
goose I don't know how you did that in
the first place but goose goose won't be
a part of that your activities are
unwarranted Oh aha right of course
ah I am a good smart goose I was
switched but I got there eventually
how many of you were yelling at me how
many how many were yelling at me give me
a big old goose and chat if you were
yelling at me because that is just
really a goose
auguste it real good guys but it's okay
it's okay guys guys I don't want to see
all the all the don't listen guys I'm
going in my own goosey pace I just got a
I got a you know I got a make goose with
what I got I I you know I've only been
blessed with so much goose you know they
gave me a
ten I got a ten out of ten goose body
but my goose brain might be just like a
five out of ten or five out of twenty I
don't know I'm not good with fractions
because of my tiny goose prey but just
look at my look at my incredible goose
caboose
you can't deny this goose got it
I feel like it's so funny because like
when I was I was yet I was warming up to
play this game and I was literally just
I can show you the goose shining
shimmering goose and all I could think
of was Ethan was like three years ago
now two years ago I have no idea two
years ago three years ago just goose
that was like his first introduction on
the channel it's just like him sprinting
by camera going goose goose and so
that's that's pretty much the initial
initial introduction that anyone ever
got we were just in the park we were
filming for I god-knows-what video we
were actually filming I don't even
remember but we were filming a video I
think it was like the twelve days of
chica
Christmas or something like that and any
time we were in the office we were just
like goose goose good I don't know does
anybody even remember that man give me a
goose in chat if you remember for the og
goose you know the original goose came
alright so I'm having way too much fun
please I don't know I don't know why
it's just this game just exudes
happiness can he basket okay we're oh I
know where I put the basket I don't know
where I put the basket where did I put
the basket where where did I put the
basket hello
hello did I bring it over here no no I
did not where did I put them in guys all
right we got a problem
I don't remember where I put the best
kit guys I don't I don't remember where
I put the basket guys my goose brains is
a little overheating oh I'm just one
goose I'm just one goose I'm just one
goose I'm just a goose I'm just one
goose I can't do a lot my goosey nature
I'm just one goose very very dumb goose
let's very dumb but but I'm cute I'm a
cute goose so you got give me that tada
[Music]
goose all right new to-do list what make
the groundskeeper hammer his thumb hell
yeah oh hell yeah
okay we're gonna make box I'm gonna make
them with this so when's he gonna be
hammering Hangu sky hey goose gardener
goose in ER hey goosey loosey goosey
goose goose no smart goose well there
are some smart gooses but uh I don't
know if it's this one all right when you
gonna be hammering what do you need to
hammer what's going on what's uh what's
your hammer and I don't even know if you
have a hammer hang on let me put this in
my shoe store Thank You Stacy thank you
so much and Alex thank you okay
let's go take this all right
excuse me hi guys this dude - - oh my
gosh dude yeah you better come over here
oh really this is another concern to you
oh it's a goose all right fine
you got to see it for yourself oh yeah
that's right yeah what are you gonna do
about nothing
[Laughter]
hey hey listen buddy listen buddy it's
not worth it why don't you just go try
to put up the side again do it do it
it'll be great yeah no it's gonna be
fine what what what hi hi why it's just
a goose just a goose man just a goose
just a goose man I guess I would be
moderately threatening oh he's dead oh
oh he's not dead okay well I guess I
can't be as happy as I was hey you gonna
hammer me next what you gonna do just a
goose listen I act I act tough on the
outside but in my in my goosey Center
I'm really just a goosey coward anyway I
got to make him wear his Sun Hat I don't
know why that's an objective I don't
even know where the Sun Hat is how do I
see the Sun Hat
did I see a sundown anywhere there's a
Sun Hat can I go get that noose no I
can't get that it's too high
goes all right well I guess I got to
bring the Sun out use my godly goose
powers to bring the clouds apart and
have the goose sunshine on my goose face
all I gotta do is really did my tail
just wiggle that is the most adorable
thing
okay what's over here I would die for
goose I would die if you would die for
goose
give me a goose inch Oh die for this
goose in a heartbeat is no question Oh
splish-splash hi hi those are some big
lays Hey oh wow you your nerd your
[Music]
cowardly you better run yeah you better
run run run run run yes right we're
gonna do against the goose Hey Oh God
lady lady I'm just trying to chase down
the nerd nerd nerd what you gonna do we
gonna do
I mean honestly geese are terrifying
this is all you could do what you do huh
we gonna do oh yeah what what of it what
if I break this bottle I will shank you
I will shank you you should be afraid
don't even try don't even try look how
big
yeah what's gonna do goose ah yeah of
course I'm bullying of course I'm
bullying Do You Know Who I am a
markiplier I'm practically a nerd nerd
Thank You ash of course we would all die
for this goose
I am glad everybody its Bob and his
young age yeah I do realize that Bob did
in fact have a crippling fear of the
goose haunted his dreams goose you
better watch out your body
oh this goose so much art what somebody
to do list break the broom trap the boy
in the phone booth I agree
make the boy wear the wrong glasses I
agree make someone buy back their own
stuff I agree get on TV
excellent go shopping put in the basket
toothbrush loo paper hairbrush tinned
food cleaner fruit and veg I love it I
love it okay
break the broom let's break this room
hey lady
excuse me I need my bot Oh kid you just
messed with the wrong ghost
Oh what you got brave what what is this
what I'm gonna get your laces oh you got
it cool aces Oh doh
what's going on got your other ones okay
the run bearer is my goose laughing
[Music]
ah I see oh he's really dumb
I'll take these thank you very much ooh
can I get on TV here hi I'm a smart
goose I'm just a real smart goose just
trying to get by my own goosey wet Wow
Wow oh you don't like goose with glasses
what's wrong with you phone booth hmm
okay interesting okay so are there any
other glasses with which I could make
this nerd where there's gotta be right
there's gotta be I think what is this
game this is goose game that's what the
oh he's so sad
Oh what hey whoa lady lady that's your
really threatening okay you're just
sweeping okay that's fine that's fine
you're fine
hey anybody seen any other glasses any
other glasses over here hey was this I'm
an intelligent goose I could figure this
out hello
[Music]
I can use from a distance I'm an
unstoppable goose all right I've got a
shield
I'm captain goose America now just try
me lady
try me try me lady lady hey try me try
me try me try
ah ah you tried ah you should I swear I
swear you tried try me
I got it try me try me try me try me
[Music]
she's too powerful
she can't be bitten by normal means
goose goose aah she's too strong
she's unbeatable she's got a fan of snap
me out of existence all right find that
fine toothbrush didn't I need a
toothbrush
yeah I didn't have a toothbrush all
right toothbrush I'm gonna put this in a
basket first time I steal a basket
oh she left opportunity glasses glasses
glasses you incus a nerd a nerd hey nerd
you stupid nerd a nerd go get him nerd
your zombie nerd I can't see Canyon you
can't see because you're dumb I can't
keep secrets you're stupid you know why
why would you do that I do that to me
how'd you do that
Guu supplier I'm willing to make it
canon I'll just a [ __ ] don't mind me I
need this basket for stuff and things
is that your mom by the way see where
you get your good looks from her okay so
in toothbrush loo paper and goose gotta
poop
goose gotta do do some business deuce
got a dugu's way hey why that's right
you don't even think about it no no hey
I'm shop I'm gonna pay for it
hey hey hey [ __ ]
that was mine I'm gonna pay for that
you're gonna pay for that when I'm done
with you oh you're gonna pay for that
no this is mine I need this that's Tracy
she's stupid so stupid so stupid so dumb
okay let's get the lube oh okay all
right I see how it is all right you take
something to mind I take something to
yours well your own weed here ah no I
want oh no please
all right fine then fine fine fine fine
you can't beat me I know how to do it
wait no no lady lady lady lady lady lady
lady lady I went out when I when I when
I will the winner I'm the winner I'm the
winner I'm the winner I win I win I win
I win every time I win can I make this
kid step on this hey kid you want step
on that you get smacked by the broom
that's gotta be a thing it has to be a
thing
no wait come here okay come here kid hey
kid come here no no no hey come here
okay trip okay take the glasses come
here you come here kid I'm gonna make
you smack yourself in your face like an
idiot here we go
set I just gotta set the bait gonna bait
the trick no no no lady lady not now not
now lady
guy hate you I hate you I hate you I
hate you I hate you I hate you I'm gonna
I'm gonna mess with your trash so I'm
gonna do and I don't mean your life
which is also trash I mean you're
literal trash I'm a mess I'm gonna
destroy you destroy you you you think
you can mess with me I'm God I could I
could destroy the universe in a single
honk you think you can mess with me it's
impossible here well oh you left here
sorry sorry
all right hey where'd you get your
glasses back oh this kid I swear oh
excuse me sorry did you want something
oh no it's the flippy the wrong way over
I'd go ah come on maybe I could oh but
oh dude oh oh oh it's flippy the wrong
way
guys it's flippy the wrong way guys guys
it's flippy the wrong way guys oh come
on I'm using my big brain here guys guys
guys
don't be no no come on no me gooo come
on
Oh No yeah good just whoopee ah life is
really hard guys it's really hard being
a goose it's really hard being a goose
it's hard hard goose fine if this is how
you're gonna be I will not
oh really you you you you get out of
there you get in there how did you see
what do you have eyes only for loo paper
is that what you are is that all you are
oh okay all right guys all right all
right listen I know how to play this
game I'm a smart I'm a smart goose I am
big brain goose and I am charging up my
big brain goose abilities but just wait
you gotta wait because I I've got this
I've got this
I've got this okay what's my objective
make someone buy back their own stuff
okay interesting get on TV okay
interesting I understand I know I know I
know
I'm genius oh no please is it it's a toy
you own this
you own this oh thank you for the assist
thank you for this thank you for the
assist yeah it's yours yeah it's yours
yeah it's yours
hey kid where's your toy at hey kid
what's going on hey kid yo incus what
can I not oh I can only kick it hey kid
come here no no no no kid kid kid god
you're such a coward you're such a
coward go buy back your own stuff you
stupid stupid it's a water pump
dear airplane go get it hey I'm not even
close to here yeah what are you doing
what no but oh it's working my master
plan
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm a master I'm a goose all right okay
all right lady I'm about to ruin your
entire existence here I'm about to ruin
everything you've ever known loved
anything you've ever entertained no I
want the basket anything you've ever
entertained as existing in this world I
am about to destroy you I am a goose you
are nothing to me I could destroy you in
a nanosecond you know how many humans
I've killed unlimited I have never had
as many kills as you would even
understand that didn't make a lot of
sense but it's because I'm speaking
secret goose language you wouldn't know
what what what that's right that's what
I thought back off lady
I think you know give gift God why would
you not give to me why would you not
give to me oh yeah yeah you stupid you
turn your back on our goose you turn
your back on a goose lived to see the
light of day again
you never turn your back on a goose what
are you stupid I put this in here all
right that's to me bring this in here
just for safety all right
nevermind oh here we go let me bring
this in just for safety
all right cool good good good now
they'll never see it okay I need hair
brushed in food cleaner Oh cleaner I saw
that it was over here it fell out of the
trashcan didn't it didn't I see a bottle
of cleaner cleaner clean then wonder
cleaner did she take it that lady took
it didn't she that lady took it I can't
believe it she took it
hey what are you doing what are you up
to what are you up to yeah that's right
that's what I thought
she took it didn't she oh yes she did
Gerst earn it I'm taking this mine mine
peace was never enough hey you I hate
you I hate you I hate how do you see me
you're blind you're old how can you even
begin to see me no don't even think
about I'm taking another one I'm taking
something else you think you've beaten
me but you are wrong so wrong never been
more wrong in your entire existence I
will destroy you I will annihilate you
you will be dust before me okay all
right that's three
I need the hairbrush I need the cleaning
product I need no no no I'm stealthy
goose egg NAB it darn goose live back to
the old farm no not what I needed
hey bud told me you can't what no you
can't how do you see me how do you see
me you're old and blind oh yeah oh yeah
this this big brain mode I've officially
done it I've done it
I've done it I've done it now I'm gonna
go the long way around cuz I doubt
there's any way that she could see me if
I'm all the way over here right no way
she's so dumb he's so stupid
you're so stupid you're so stupid you're
so stupid
I've got oh I'm so stupid I'm so stupid
good goose here we go alright fine we
got this hey lady how are you doing how
you been hey you good oh oh that's weird
I thought I had a greeter no you don't
you're dumb I'm smart there we go oh
yeah I just need the poop paper just got
a wipe my goose ass on all your loo
paper the brush here gotta keep my
beautiful haired shape you'll never
catch me alive you'll never take me
alive welp I'm think I'm being attacked
well I thought I saw some doily baby I
need my old feeble behind stupid lady
it's so stupid you got out goose big
time goose is on the loose hurry up and
done no and done shopping yes I'm so
goddamn smart
I am beyond smart I'm the smartest that
there ever were alright time to trap the
boy in the phone booth I mean there's
gotta be a way there has to be a way for
me to get that kid to smack his face on
this broom I bet it's like a secret okay
this is the right way this is the right
way okay good good good
could bring us as far down south as I
can she won't see me she won't see me
she has no idea she has no idea where
did my broom go Oh ever since my husband
divorced me I've only got sweeping and
was chasing him that's really sad I
didn't mean I did I apologize for
nothing what did I say I'm the bully of
YouTube and I stand by my words okay
hey kid I kid I nice Lacey you got dude
oh god why aren't you scared my scared
you incus oh dear Hank are you going
stupid stupid idiot
I'm gonna it's this is gonna work come
here you go beer
come here yep cook keep coming up right
here come here kid good come hear my
voice
well come on do it do it do it kid do it
do it do it do it I swear to God do it
ah
this game is unplayable it's stupid so
literally unplayable over here come here
come in I'm gonna make you do it you're
gonna do it you're gonna run okay I'm
gone okay fine then there you go I've
gave them to you cuz I'm so nice but I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna honk you're
right into that I'm gonna honk you right
into it what'd you do you did juice run
run ah okay all right here yeah you
gonna get it now
goose it's impossible it's impossible it
can't be done it's a pocket simp I god
this game is unplayable this game is
garbage this game is this is the worst
game ever made in the history of forever
this game is awful this game is garbage
no one no one can do it no one it's
impossible it's impossible it's
impossible ok I got a trap the child all
right how do I trap the child huh how do
I trap this child first off how do I get
the phone booth even open in the first
place kick hey we're playing a game
hey we're friends Wow
why would you do something like that
hmm okay what about in here what about
this how do I get in there there's a lot
of mysteries abound a lot of mysteries
abound hey dish get out of here
goose goose incoming okay in the both
gain the both oh that's easy
how are you gonna do well you gotta do
what you gonna do right will you call it
calling oh I don't know what to do what
are you gonna do huh I'm in love on TV
I'm beautiful beautiful I always thought
I should be on TV I'm goddamn gorgeous
of God why trap the shopkeeper in the
garage I like that idea
I like that idea a lot where's this
garage where's the garage ah here I see
Oh interesting interesting interesting
okay I think I have an understanding of
how I would do this hey how are you hey
where's your poop paper what is that
what do you draw was that your iron hip
what is that your Metamucil canister I
didn't even break the rake yet her
though not the rake that the broom hey
I'm stealing your whoa I'm stealing your
colonoscopy device you better come get
it probably really important to you
considering how many calls colonoscopies
you probably need hey lady
are you where's your yeah you get better
get your speculum it's in here
hey you're so dumb you would come after
me in a hot second last time and now you
won't do it
get the girls don't shoo the goose get
the girl I'm stealing your toy stealing
your toy it's me
stealing your toy come here come here
you don't want this I've got your
property
all right fine I'm gonna get your price
gun hi hey you doing what are you doing
what's going on what are you doing what
are you doing
where'd I go I got your baby what you
gonna do about it
we got your baby you're not gonna come
to find your baby yeah you better hey
hey hey hey that's that's not fair
I want it come here give me your baby
give me your baby what are you doing
what are you doing okay your baby your
baby
oh you suck why do you suck the answer
is you do come on
no God no you're so fast how for an old
lady are you this fast this should be
impossible your your feeble bones
shouldn't be able to go the speed oh
yeah this time I've got your number my
baby my baby oh and my colonoscopy
device okay what what what why are you
having why would I why would I go that
way why would I go that way why would I
go that way your sack we gonna do you
new broom
all right fine I'm gonna take something
else oh yeah I can give me we're gonna
be come on go god damn it go go go go
God why swear I swear I win I will watch
as you still slowly starve as you beg
for your life when you when I'm done
watching you waste away to nut Oh
Oh real oh really really lady really
really you're gonna you guys push me you
gonna I will trap you in there again
when done with you swear eyes it's what
is this what is this this is spacious
days this isn't even a good this is a
duck
this ain't no goose goose you think
you're a goose you you think you goose I
will not stand for this this is wrong I
just think about what side of history
you're standing on huh think about the
thing about there oh you want your broom
up give your broom give your broom I
swear I swear you think that I will just
go easy on you you think I will go easy
on you
the answer is I will not the answer is I
absolutely will not go easy on you I
will destroy you in every way shape and
form you think that mercy is something
that I even comprehend no no I will
watch The Life Drain from your where did
you go there you are okay I will watch
The Life Drain from your eyes as I take
that which you love the most
away from you try me try me what what
try me try me try me try me try me try
me was that the wrong end with the wrong
end you're Metamucil oh you don't want
to have irregular bowel movements to you
you you specious piece of garbage you
are the worst
you humans disgust me okay I'm out of
here
that's it so enough for you you will
waste away and you will die and I will
live on eternal coz I am goose and
you're nothing when compared to the
mighty goose the mighty goose has no
mercy
the mighty goose only knows pain and
suffering in the
of you I will destroy you I will destroy
everything you've ever known never loved
brassiere if there's any proof in this
world that I have really points out the
fact that I go on my goosey way
excuse me goose coming through this is
the goose caboose is loose better grab
me my girthy goose eNOS will not be
denied hello hi how are you you look
mighty fine
what most articles I detect the cook a
goose I could swear that might have been
a goose around here
but alas I exterminated all the goose in
the great goose war of 1932 that
couldn't possibly be a goose here oh I
guess he really wouldn't pay no mind to
that make someone break the fancy Vaz
help the woman dress up the bust make
the man spit out his tea get dressed up
with a ribbon make the mango barefoot do
the washing of course goose
mmm
egads I've been had what hey you've got
the wrong [ __ ] on the get the wrong
[ __ ] I'm gonna make you spill your d
you didn't see nothin
got the wrong [ __ ] on the uppy uppy
this guy's paranoid
this guy's paranoid what's that lady is
that a goose my word no no no no you
don't see me why why would you do this
oh geez did that not count as barefoot
how do I get both of his feet I will
destroy you I hope you know this I hope
you realize this I will destroy you I am
a goose that knows no mercy I'm a goose
that will haunt all of your dreams right
in your crotch stupid what that didn't
count be kidding me
that didn't count Oh spit out his tea
not spill it
ah I'm dumb excuse me excuse me just a
goose hey wait no come back
all right fine then fine fine fine just
cuz you got tea on your crotch to get
this fine whatever
you stupid a-hole I'm gonna destroy what
what GV sees me right now taking it what
this is not what I wanted to take my man
dignified goose I'm a dignified goose I
shouldn't
I've done it I've broken it we're making
someone break the man he goes how do I
do this how do I make someone break the
fancy Lowe's you want this what hey
burrs ear Hey look I've got the Brezina
excuse me I've got your bra pardon me
scuse me up toe okay can hardly believe
this how do i reset this bad boy can i
reset this bad boy oh oh did I waste my
one opportunity to make him spit I hope
not oh oh
interesting interesting
where does this lead oh oh must get
these three set I can't have it are you
gonna rebuild that wow that's really
impressive lady wait
hi hello put your flappity flap you're
drinking your tea yet hey so you should
get thirsty
yeah remember it's tea time it's
whatever the heck time it is stop being
so paranoid and just drink your damn tea
everything's fine I'm like drooling at
this ham sweet hammer this hammer Sunday
night yeah drink sip sip sip the tea of
death sip it no don't you dare this is
my mom all right I need a bar of soap
for something I don't know how to do the
laundry but I'm gonna steal your soap
okay so the bust is there interesting
now where would I do laundry at is
laundry to be done over here I think you
would kill a goose nope my bow mine mine
mine mine
I am hidden you don't know where I am
how is this possible
how does how does humans have this power
get away from me stop it all right there
you're done Oh fight fight or make love
how do I wear this can I wear this get
dressed up with a ribbon
I want to how do I do it how do I do it
no no what what are you doing what are
you doing what do you want the ribbon
get away from the ribbon what are you
doing hey stranger danger help please
stop I don't want it please up ah you
are the biggest a-hole
I've ever known I can't believe you oh I
can't believe you you two suck harder
than anyone I've ever known to suck I
can't believe you I'm stealing your
bread stealing it you'll never get it
back you'll never ever get it back
you're never gonna get it back oh god
here I went the wrong way
I never might believe you stupid idiot
you thought you could get away from the
brassiere you thought I can't pin that
there I'm stealing the soap stealing the
soap the soap is mine and you suck the
soap tastes delicious by the way I'm
stealing a sock as well okay I'm stuck
in a wall here but you I hate you a pair
of socks why do I need a pair of socks
why do I need a full pair my sock almost
as vital as my brassiere whoo dude
you'll never get it back you'll never
get it back you will never get it back
in the history of forever
you will no pain can you whoa oh he's
looking okay I'm just gonna get
everything to stage two that's the key
that's the trick yeah what do you do
about your brassiere nothing you can do
where'd your newspaper go your
newspapers right here you idiot
here take it thank you you're welcome
dummy I've got a sock I'm a stealthy
goose with a sock excuse me
goose coming through what what what no
what how you I swear I swear I said it's
in it's in the drink now it's in the
drink it's gone and you know what you
know it's next the brassiere that you
stole from me that's my bra that's my
bra that is my bra
what you gonna do stop it yes yeah what
what you suck why can't you be a
perverted old man let's steal this other
sock taking this taking this nothing you
can do about there's literally nothing
you can do about it God you did
something about it
why your I hate you all I hate every of
you I'm taking this well you're never
gonna stop me you're never in the
history if we're ever gonna stop me I am
an unbeatable goose I'm the strongest
goose in the entire you read your
goddamn paper Oh
sprint sprint goose waggle then what
okay all right I am unbeatable can you
hear that
why can't you hear that how can you hear
that where'd that other sock go it's on
the line it's mine now mine right you
will need you will know pain you will
know true pain get away for why am i
running oh I hate you I hate you so much
I hate you I hate you I hate you I will
burn down your crops I'll burn down your
house I'll burn down every
you've ever known it ever loved I'm
taking this run-run goose give to me run
run run huh
right why are you now running well you
can't run with a sock who I never why am
I not running go finally freakin finally
alright make it make it make it make it
make it make it make it make it stop
this guy
I swear yes I know my goose is dummy
thick and the slap of my mighty feet
hell hurts my presence I'm aware of this
a slipper slipper mister mister
I need a slipper mister mister Easter
Easter Easter mark it's a stealth game
you don't know that it's not a stealth
game it's a game of aggression whoosh I
aggressively stealthily took that
aggressively pure unadulterated
aggression this vaz needs to die so
decrees me the mighty goose where'd you
go oh oh the mighty thick goose that is
right this goose is mighty this goose is
thick this goose will not be denied this
goose is sick I bet I bet I bet
lick someone break the fancy face how
they do that make someone break the
fancy pitcher everyone stop stop what
you doing and listening to me I am about
to use my giant brain thank someone
break the fancy face I know what this
means
I know what this means I know how to do
this I know and I'm willing to bet I'm
willing to bet I'm willing to bet a
sweet like that I've got the solution
right now I've got the solution I bet a
sweet like if I'm wrong about this then
I'm wrong here
hey wait if I'm wrong you out you can
dislike all you want but if I'm right if
I'm right that see I bet that means you
have to give me a sweet like guys you
have to that's part of the arrangement
this part of the arrangement you gotta
give me a sweet like how is that
standing up on that son that doesn't
make any sense guys you gotta give me a
sweet like you gotta give me a sweet
like it's it's part of it see that see
this is what happens
we make fun deals we make cool
arrangements and everything's good now
what do I gotta do help the woman dress
up the bust hi you don't want that what
you talking about how do we dress up
this bust nobody needs a bra new he
needs a
that can't have a ball boss you need a
hat on that bust hey bud
what are you doing are you doing going
in for the kill
stealth game my nards still came my left
nipple you'll never get me her yet lady
my good would you God zukes
how would I put this in the ball here
you'd love this wouldn't ya go ahead put
it hoop opis hacks mmm that yeah put it
on the bust put it on there yeah pretty
good pretty good how about the pipe
about the pipe maybe the bus could use a
sweet pipe maybe just stick it right in
the marble there yeah yeah yeah that's a
good thing yeah there you go
Oh pipe funkalicious let me just make
out with this fish over here yeah what
about that if we stick it right in there
yeah that's fine all right now glasses
this this old man I'm taking everything
he's ever loved it's my chance my chance
oh oh god please no I need that
give to me no please I need I'm the best
I'm the best I'm the best there ever was
I'm the best I'm the genius I'm the
genius best love a gingy best there one
glasses I've never seen these before
hell you suck there now the bust of
oldie Eustace is complete I can remember
my husband
wander up luli garden I don't know why
everyone's dead here hey can I make out
with this okay so how do I get dressed
up with a ribbon
that's the question here ah no no lady
no okay
so how would I get dressed up with a
ribbon
I know I know exactly how I know exactly
how wait wait I know how I know how I
thought it was okay I see what I have to
do I have to get rid of the competition
here I just have to hide the competition
take this bow where you had lady okay I
see what I need to do there we go
perfect perfect
perfect perfect come on but it's me it's
me is be is me your precious goose
statue is I'm this is perfect it's
perfect it's no God don't look there
don't look there look at the bow oh you
can't fail you can't see me you can't
find a catch but you can't see you can't
catch what you can't see you can't catch
what you can't see you have no idea you
have no idea you've lost me forever
you'll never find it
ever ever no wait you can't guess what
you can see now I just need to bury this
body perfect right there there we go
perfect what here's me you must be blood
she's cannot how could she know it's me
well I've been here is be this Bo peeps
why you I'm utterly convinced
[Music]
what no what do you mean oh I see
because the body is ah I see okay all
right well you listen lady listen lady
lady listen to me listen lady you need
to get the stick out of your ass and
listen to me I hate you I will ruin your
life I will destroy your entire exert
everything you have ever known and ever
loved I'm going to destroy everything
[Music]
get up get up get up I'm gonna kill this
competitor goose I'm either gonna [ __ ]
this goose or I'm going to chop this
goose into next century give me the bow
what do you suspect foul play that
doesn't work with Mises but what was
that nothing what could it have been
it's just a goose it's just your normal
GU statue did you just try to listen
[Music]
[Laughter]
guys I did it I did it I did it guys
that deserves a sweet like if ever there
was anything that proves I have a big
brain and that I am deserving of a sweet
like it's the fact that I have a bow I
did it I did it okay I did it
okay make the man go barefoot make
someone prune the
prize rows interesting make someone
prune the prize rows a make the man go
barefoot you say it was a lie it was a
lie the entire time a lie and now I have
a pretty pretty bow I have a pretty
pretty bow it was over here there's
nothing over looks like I could break
through it but apparently not okay the
prize rose
where are your shears have you just
accepted the fact that I'm gonna wear
this bow because if you take it away
from me I'm gonna really be bad okay
apparently not okay hey cheers you see
someone's gonna trim this Primrose but I
don't know who it's gonna be
how do i how would I get this lady to
trim this prize rose or maybe not the
lady maybe the man's gonna trim his own
rose
I bet those wrong mark Oh goose in
trouble we got a goose down no lady
please ah lady are you gonna chop my
head off
yeah dude do it do it I dare you I dare
you do it you wouldn't we gonna do okay
so I can't bring that over there but I
could grab it and go through the gate so
that must be the way to do it so I'm
gonna do that I'm I'm gonna do that okay
that's besides the point I need to stop
being ridiculous this is a very serious
game what is this what is this yeah my
competitor of course excuse me pardon me
is what no don't my book this is my ball
I don't know what you're talking about
hmm I know it's changed but I do know
okay so what I need to do I need to get
her to trim this the tail off of that
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah okay
okay okay all right okay all right okay
I don't like that I look in chat and it
says mess with her bush because that's
I'm really eating the squirrels ass
[Laughter]
tastes like nuts I'm sorry guys I would
like to humbly apologize it's just
oh no it came over me guys I don't
understand what happened to me I feel
like feel like something's very wrong
with me all right
aren't you uh what'd you give her an old
trim huh what are you gonna do lady how
do I make this man go barefoot how do I
make you go bare for what what what what
do something old man do something I dare
you I dare you I dare you oh that's how
weak that's his other foot oh you think
you're so clever
yo incus you can't catch what you can
see you've lost me lost me there it is
or where is it where is it my friend you
have no idea because you're stupid my
rose how could you do this to me I don't
know I scarce all the sudden but
everybody's just rolling it how could
you do this to me my rose
[Laughter]
you guys can't see because my face is
blocking it but the curse is gone no the
only happiness in me life it'll never
grow back it'll never grow back it'll
die and wither it's already dead the
only difference is it doesn't look like
it right now and you will die cold alone
sad your wife gone her husband gone and
you can't see the love that's there but
the two of you you are pathetic
and you are sad reading your newspaper
or like a fool didn't even feel your
tootsies
why it can't breathe I can't decide if
I'm Scotties or not okay goodbye
where are ya okay goodbye what this is
this is ridiculous
this is absurd I'm out of here
what
my bow
[Music]
okay anyway what what why oh thanks
thank you up dig I'm not entirely sure
what happened there all right whatever
you're taking your mail away I don't
know where I'm gonna put it but I know
it's gonna go in the garbage you know I
knew I did this for a reason I knew
there was a reason for this I knew I
knew there was a reason for this I knew
it I knew it all along
I knew I knew
goodbye good luck on your journey I knew
there was a reason that I brought the
rake over here I knew it I knew it all
along
also why did he throw the badminton with
me oh please tell me yeah mail yes
please thank you needed this for stuff
and things is this this lady's mail well
too bad not anymore
I'm taking this I don't know where and I
don't know why but I'm taking this look
fish code Oh something I haven't thought
about Negus yeah the old fish code and I
do remember it fondly I remember it very
very hello hello hello hello oh hey you
look like an old Italian man hey you
look like that bust hey does your wife
know you're not dead and your wife has
been mourning over you painting the
painting of you for you oh [ __ ] oh you
got remarried Oh God
or you diss your mistress oh [ __ ] okay
excuse you lady that's really rude why
would you be rude like that I don't like
your tude hey listen I ain't ain't no
thang I don't judge I don't judge a lot
I'm gonna untie it your shoes ease you
shoot all gone God that's what you're
gonna do about it
don't shoot me I'll unsure you shoot
you're gonna die you're gonna be buried
in a shallow grave
you only never gonna see the light of
day again Hey
you think that you could see the light
of day no I'm gonna destroy everything
you know yeah that's right make your
girlfriend do all the work while you sit
around like a lazy sack of bum you know
stupid I hate you I'm running I'm making
a break for it okay all right well can I
get my badminton racquet yeah whoo yeah
give me okay fine whatever
because I'm not welcome here no one
likes gooses I know I know I know I know
this metal gear it's metal goose solid
it's metal goose hey lady lady hey lady
I'm getting my bad man in there nope
bring him this in you can't stop me get
it in there okay we're in
I don't know I'm bringing this bad man
their bull we're in we're in whirring
we're going for it when's she gonna
where is she where is this lazy sack of
bones there she is
listen lady there's a nice badminton in
here why does everything I love get
taken away from me all right I'm in I'm
in baby oh I'm in better hope I'm not
cook for dinner but I'm in oh yeah I'm
in okay where am I going wait no hey I
want to be out there there I want to be
where the people are out there where
they're always happy I want to see those
what Yuma call it dick I don't know okay
goodbye
see you around I see you around hey
ticket see you take care okay yeah we're
freaking okay I'm stuck in the box there
we go that's good okay what is going on
here what's this what's behind here it's
that no goose sign if that is I'm gonna
be very pissed I'll be very upset you
know how upset I will be
okay apparently there's nothing here for
me there's nothing at all there's no
thing okay hello
do I have objectives Oh break the
dartboard get the toy boat make the old
man fall on his bum I love that one and
right onto a knife be awarded a flower
steal a pint glass and drop it into the
canal set the table
okay you seem all like reasonable
requests what is what what why why is
what what is what what what am I look
what am I looking at what what is this
what is this what what what what
I'm not arms and sure I understand what
that was this is a plate do I need this
to set the table
probably all right goose away hello just
a wittle waddle of a goose oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh God
you cats get looks okay - it'll waddle
of a little goose coming through don't
mind a little water there's a fork ah no
it's lady please I just bring you the
plate mixing all of your beautiful ink
which is here listen lady lady listen
you don't need to be bothered killed no
worries is this the table I need to set
what table would stay what we talking
about here which table we talking about
cuz uh I can't seem to reach many so I'm
just gonna shrinkage okay I don't like
this lady I don't like Bertha over here
gimme that toy was it just get the toy
boat
give me the toy I want the toy give me
the toy don't lady late lady
I swear I swear you think that you can
mess with the likes of me but you cannot
lady lady lady listen lady lady you're
so pretty but you need to go you need to
go you need to go away and lady lady
lady all right come on come on come on
come on yeah this is what we're talking
about here ah I hate you I hate you I
hate you so much
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme yes i lady please please I just
want to join you for dinner uh-huh
you don't know where I am okay maybe you
okay this this lady might be kind of not
she dumb she a little too dumb for her
own good
she's a little too dumb okay what did I
need to do with the boat nothing I just
needed to get the boat okay so there's
got to be a table here what is this
boink oops is that olive oil is that
some weird wine
I don't know this table no not that
table this table no I almost died I
almost died okay okay okay
I almost died but it's okay it's okay oh
well all right then there goes the
bucket I don't know why I need the
bucket maybe I don't need the bucket
maybe the table isn't over here maybe
the table is inside my heart maybe it's
been maybe it's the table on the inside
that counts or maybe it's the table the
quote-unquote table over here with this
tablecloth you know what I mean cuz
otherwise why would you be able to go
here and why would the plate be right
here you know what I'm talking about I'm
thinking that that might be the table
which
I gots to go get me some silverware Oh
lady ooh you don't care okay that's good
to know hey it's alright
hey we all good here we're friends we're
friends can we drop dead there let me go
get what did I need pepper candle how do
I get the pepper pepper Commission
pepper please dad's can't zukes can't
zooks I'm stuck
gadzooks alright it's okay it's okay
it's okay why you gotta be like wow you
scary lady
Dagny I lost - [ __ ] my pepper nope get
in the hall
okay okay so okay so good so good baby
yeah okay I just need the fork a candle
and a knife yeah I've got this make a
new try not tell I literally made one
yesterday what more do you want from me
you greedy greedy people I can't believe
that I can't believe it how could you
ask so much of me okay all right we're
on the way to a knife we're on the way
to a candle we've got this hey lady lady
listen where's a candle ah perfect
perfect for goose perfect for goose
excuse me lady hey lady
hey lady what do you think you see who
shoot she sees me oh no she don't see me
oh no she don't know my candle junk hey
what's going on oh [ __ ]
and shine kiss no no no no no no no no
no my candle my is my knife
cup Gooden through the gap just go the
whole guy I hate you I hate lady I hate
you no don't you dare I'm going for it
I'm going for it no no no no no no no no
you suck I hate you give me Jaden Oh
believe it that goose is sword issues so
dastardly so dastardly but yeah and yet
there's something about that goose it's
enticing in a weird way I know must be
the caboose no ink
okay one more I think this is right this
feels right then I always go with my gut
feeling over literally anything else are
you that you stole you stole it for me
I'm sorry this is mine
not and away good thing they can't hear
the pitter-patter of my feet my Tootsie
footsies or else they might get a little
bit concerned sorry excuse me I'm a
goose I know no better you can't blame
me I'm just a goose with an amazing
caboose flap oh Jesus I've never known
anyone smarter than me there's literally
no one that could possibly be ever
smarter than me
I'm undeniably smart unbeatably smart
I'm incredibly smart goose my goose
knows no bound ok break the dartboard I
don't even know where a dart board is be
awarded a flower Steel pint glass and
dropping in the canal all right I'll
make that the last thing I do because
that means I got to get out of here then
I would have to sneak back in if it was
you oh the old man you're the old man
what in tarnation's what is this hello
oh we're communicating
loose loose oh wow goose whoa I'm a good
goose give me a flower thank you thank
you so much thank you that was really
nice I think they like me I think they
like me
I think they God I look over at chat and
I just see make them goose cheeks clap
and I realize how little hope there is
left for the human species I just I I
have this lovely exchange with these
people here and then I look over and
someone makes me think about clapping
goose ass and I that you know you'd
think that would be the the lowest that
low could be oh you broke your hip oh
yeah yeah you broke it you broke it all
yeah sorry he'll never be never be okay
again sorry excuse me
dartboard how do I break a dartboard how
do I break it how do I break a dartboard
oh oh you're really bad at that I don't
know about that cat away brick how would
anyone break a dartboard they would
throw a dart that's too big to throw at
it right yeah hey come at me charge me
as like a bowl
[Music]
okay okay he's going for a dart ah okay
okay oh so stupid also really strong
oddly strong I don't I don't know about
that one I don't know drop a bucket on
the burly man's head I agree
wholeheartedly with this I know exactly
how to do this
Oh shooty ray how you doing oh I see
are you the burly man you might get your
own little taste of bucket heaven wait
what are you going for I don't know what
that's for lady to be perfectly honest I
don't know what this for hello don't
mind me just a goose hey buddy
hey you the burly man you the oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh god no Sam I Sandra danger
stranger danger
okay flower what you gonna take the
flower that I was awarded away from me
is that really what you're gonna do is
that really what you're gonna do with
your life no don't
what are you really that curious are you
really that curious and lady are you
gonna take every plate away from me is
that really what you're gonna do right
now is that really what you're about to
do right now are you gonna take the
plate the candle the fork are you gonna
take that all the way because if you do
I swear I hate will hate you I'm gonna
hide it so you never see it ever again
stupid is what you get stupid is what
you get all your hopes and dreams gone
stupid can you can any of you at home
you lovely people I don't believe that
stupid lady officially run out of jokes
oh sorry guys I've officially run out
I've got nothing left okay
she's gone for this no goose sign
because she hates goose and that's dumb
what do you made the pepper don't there
is no pepper
there's no pepper just go for the goose
sign there's no candle either funny
your little AI brain can't process this
just go for the goose' oh there's no
fork either oh there's no nice weird
how about that huh go for the goose son
so he can clear a path so I can drop
bucket on the burly man before I mistake
you for the burly man to drop a bucket
on your head
stupid there you go
that's what you get no you listen to me
oh oh I know oh it's perfect
tur mater oh I know oh I know oh I know
I know exactly what needs to be done I
know exactly where is the I'm looking
for the big lady I don't care about that
lady I know exactly what needs to be
done
Oh burly man Oh burly man burly man yeah
where'd I go where am I
I'm going it's a mystery dagnabbit I
can't believe it he's gone that
audaciously handsome goose is gone oh
where could he have run off to uh well
donations
dagnabbit I guess I'll never be able to
catch him that handsome goose is gone
forever
I'd best return this tomato back to its
original place where oh where could it
go wait what where's it going where's he
going Oh
but alright okay alright can I take
these boxes away from you you stupid
okay all right okay okay all right
two can play this game huh now there's
only one possible place with this tomato
could go right follow me follow me
excuse me pond me whoa wait he's not
following me is he oh hi lady listen
it's me the pretty goosey gave a flower
today hey listen are you maybe that's
not quite right
mahtim gosh darn it my tomatoes very
vanished they vacated the premises I can
hardly believe this this is ludicrous Oh
gadzooks let me just see if he puts that
tomato back in that box or if he's gonna
hunt round for uh another box Oh tomato
lying here on the ground I best put it
in this box hmm this seems probably
quite right okay so he's gonna put it in
the closest box that's what I know I
know this hey sir come with me hey come
with me are you gonna I got your tomato
I've got your tomato what are you gonna
do about it what you gonna do what are
you gonna do what do you know nothing
are you gonna do what are you gonna do
what you gonna do oh there it is
put it back in this box do it get it put
it back and he's going for it go for it
he's going for it I'm gonna get it he's
going for it he's going for it I'm so
smart I'm so smart lady you get out of
here right now
oh yes my opportunity my chance one
chance if you had one chance would you
blow it I'm will not get rekt you stupid
[ __ ] you got goosed oh you stupid it
looks like you murdered somebody
so dub blink what this is ridiculous
what in the tarnish this must be some
crazy magic a job well done oh wait oh
god I could have gotten him again twice
in a row oh this bucket seems to be in
my way
oh no he's stuck oh no can't process
this conundrum this capacity I've been
broken fine ruining my fun I can't
believe you I'm gonna get him I'm gonna
get him again egads once more I've been
goosed alright guys I'm done I'm done
nice work goose okay it's fine but hey
what are you doing it hey listen goodbye
see you around sayonara
fare thee well have a good day I'll see
you I'll catch you on the flip it if I
can I'll get the catch you on the
flippity-flop blink got it
nailed it I'm the best there ever was
where am I now
where am i where am I now wait a minute
is this where that locked gate is I bet
it is a bit it's a locked gate oh it is
oh [ __ ] it is okay alright okay good
great good great that means that we are
drain okay that means that we are very
close you make a good point there Chad
you do you raise a good point you raise
a great point actually I have neglected
something very very very important I've
neglected something incredibly important
[Music]
I'm gonna get all the goose ladies with
this goose call goose goose oh well I
don't like this place is horrifying oh
it's a model of the actual village as
weird and creepy
I see Oh gardener lose-lose
Oh lady I sure did ruin your life the
goose goose I feel so powerful
wait is that a model of someone looking
at the model news
Wow do I do it loose what do I do
it's obviously important over here hello
oh oh [ __ ] oh god ghosts all know the
pain of couse I knew that I was a god of
destruction goosy pain oh god oh god
hello I've done it
Oh take it all the way back home you
know I will oh I've done it I've done it
I've done it I've done it
I've taken it no one can stop me take
that old lady that's what your kids but
I'm gonna knock over every single one of
these before I leave I am a god of
destruction I will see your entire
civilization toppled and burned I will
burn it all to the ground everything
will be destroyed everything shall be
torn asunder can this be torn asunder I
will tear this to the ground I don't
destroy your beautiful town will be
destroyed you will know pain you will
know true agony lady I will come back
for that oh yes you will know suffering
oh yes oh I cry goose to the heavens
[Laughter]
okay oh I love it so much
oh yeah all right you survived another
day all right is there anything else
here I could break oh forgot about this
goose goose goose the horrible goosey
call
goes all right wait there we go
[Laughter]
here's huge would reduce sorry I'm
having too much fun
here's I just got to make sure
everything's destroyed properly before I
leave you out shovel
gone flowers trampled you in the lake in
I said in the lake there you go
I'm gonna go back and get the Bell real
quick before I get too far away from it
my sweet delicious Bell Goose Zilla yes
yes the truest goosey goose in the drink
in the water and the Bell is wait what's
this over here is this a secret it's our
secret over here can I climb on here
no gasps too big my goosey caboose is
too girthy too much juice in the caboose
over this way
hello no lies only lies all right
farewell it was good knowing you thank
you all so much I'll see you around I uh
I don't have the key for this do i how
do I get through here hmm maybe the keys
maybe the janitors keys or what make
that possible it would be wouldn't it
this is gonna alert everyone to my
presence isn't it ding dong ding you li
dong Li I'm a goose what is that well oh
god oh god oh god oh god well this is a
problem
Oh Oh God what in tarnation's is that
dreadful sound oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god go go god damn it go go yeah my
bail later hey my bail that's mine I
will fight you to the death for this
bill Oh God ha ha is mine no it's mine
hey gadzooks got goose goose nukes
gadzooks
Oh God Oh God
give give yeah you better tell you shoot
come on god damn it it's very
complicated it's very complicated
Oh God stop being stupid oh stop in
stupid you just give me give me the bill
give me the bill I just want the Bell
okay straight shot straight shot this
way oh yeah you've lost the trail now
the scent is gone where am I now
where am i where am I where is this
place where am I I don't know where I am
oh that's wrong hmm okay there's gotta
be a way everything's locked he's got to
be a way back
ah ah yes lady lady no no no no no no no
no no no no get what you fixed it
how'd you fix it
how'd you fix it I hate you what what
what what what I'm gonna I'm gonna break
it again and then I'm gonna climb back
over and I'm gonna be gone out of here
sorry you suck that's what you Oh God
Oh God how no no no no God you suck you
suck nope nope
you suck stop don't you don't don't you
dare don't you dare that's right ha why
drop it ha ok it's fine it's fine
leave me alone no no no no you will not
you will not throw that you will not
stop in the world you got me okay it's
fine it's fine
you got soggy feet that's what you get
oh okay I'm on the prowl I'm on the
prowl no one will ever know no one will
ever suspect anything no one will ever
know no one will ever suspect no one
will never ever know
no one will never ever suspect oh you
lady I thought you were dead I thought
you had a heart attack and died didn't I
leave you trapped in that that forbidden
garage for millennia and I didn't know
that's not your product you don't get oh
wait you're different
oh no wait you're not you're the TV
salesman oh I'm sorry
sorry sir ah kid you run away why are
you brave now guy you suck
my cool get out here you suck so hard
we drown you really get stuck no kid
stop in brain stop no I will not go
really oh my god I swear I swear
ooh I just grabbed it okay bye visit is
it this is on the way I'm out of here
you suck I hate you and everything you
do in this therefore is horrible oh I
missed my exit
I missed my exit by that much go away
you suck you suck you suck by the way
did I mention that you suck did I
mention that you suck thank you can I go
now thank you
and I'm in the bush does this guy still
locked in here I would imagine yes
goodbye
stupid it is stupid idiot they're all
stupid and dumb and I'm smart ingenious
I've done it I've done it I've done it
the Bell is mine I've done it they all
can suck my goose dog I can make it all
go to goose hell yes I've done it I've
done it I've done it I've done it so
good oh yeah wait I just remember there
are a bunch of bells in my nest my
goosey nest my goose nest my goose yes
yes yes yes yes yes
I've done it I've done it
I did I did I ruined everyone's lives in
the meaning in the time during the tap
voice acting introducing a goose is a
goose goose guys we did it
best game best game got a dead hundred
out of a hundred hundred million out of
a million it's the best game every
qualification forget this best by far
good escape bestest game that ever
existed there is no better game this is
the best game in the history of forever
there is no better game
there's nobody it's a true it's a fact
it's the fact its truth there's nothing
better there will be nothing better
never anything better it's all the
goodest that ever existed right here
right now I love this game is good good
best game best game best game best game
ever
[Laughter]
goose it will they don't know game that
this developer makes will ever live up
to the glory that is this game it is
once and done forever chants press X to
honk wave
wait there's more
there's boy there's more goose goose the
goose never dies the goose goes on all
right I don't have time to do this now
but it's a wonderful game wonderful game
fantastic game lovely game best game
astonishing game goodest game greatest
game best game there's no other game
nearly as good good good game great game
good game best game unbelievable goose
so thank you everybody so much for
watching this is it for goose game from
me if you want to play the rest of this
for yourself why not this is a fantastic
game you would not be remiss to play
this game because it is just gosh darn
great thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to see other cool
videos that I've done check out my
channel there's just a goddamn ton of
them I got a new try to have to laugh
yesterday and a whole new smorgasbord of
games are coming very soon hit that like
button if you goose if you part of the
original goose gang you subscribe for
more goose content coming at you cotton
goose you get ready for more goose
coming your way because you can't handle
the amount of loose caboose that is set
loose and in your neighborhood your
neighborhood
so get ready smash that like button
smash that subscribe and ring the bell
oh it's perfect it's perfect for me
shelling out ring the goose bell if your
real true goose if your true goose you
ring that bell to be notified of more
goose content coming your way
hi Navy that belt down there that belt
down there you got to ring that Bell
just like the good goose that you are
don't be fooled
you ain't no fake goose you real goose
you goose og original goose you part the
goose gang now so ring the bell and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye goose goose goose bye